en este vídeo veremos los radios
atómicos y radios iónicos empecemos
primero con el radio atómico si piensas
en un átomo como una esfera la idea de
radio atómico es simple imaginaremos a
esta circunferencia como una esfera y en
la esfera tenemos un radio fijo y
definido esa es una manera de pensar en
ello el problema es que un átomo no
tiene un radio fijo y definido como el
ejemplo de la esfera porque hay un
núcleo
y luego está esta nube de electrones o
esta probabilidad de encontrar tu
electrón por lo que no hay una frontera
clara que encontrar y es difícil tener
un radio fijo y definido lo que hacen
los químicos es tomar dos átomos
idénticos enlazados estos son dos átomos
unidos entre sí del mismo elemento y si
encuentras sus núcleos
digamos que esos son sus núcleos y mides
la distancia entre esos dos núcleos esta
sería nuestra distancia de entre
nuestros dos núcleos si tomas la mitad
de esta distancia esa sería una buena
aproximación del radio atómico de uno de
esos átomos esa es la idea atrás de la
definición de radio atómico veamos las
tendencias para el radio atómico y
primero empecemos con tendencias de
grupo así que aquí tenemos dos elementos
encontrados en el grupo uno
el hidrógeno y el litio y continuamos
dibujando los átomos primero empezamos
con el hidrógeno que tiene un número
atómico de 1 lo que significa que tiene
un protón en el núcleo aquí está nuestro
núcleo para el hidrógeno un protón es un
átomo neutro el número de protones es
igual al número de electrones por lo que
deberá de haber un electrón
continuaremos dibujando a nuestro
electrón aquí y haremos las cosas muy
simples y solo mostraremos esta versión
simple del átomo aunque no sabemos cómo
se ve exactamente y con el litio con un
número atómico de 3 significa que hay 3
protones en el núcleo del litio esto
representa el núcleo de litio con 3
protones y 3 electrones dos de esos
electrones están en el orbital más
cercano al núcleo así que déjame mostrar
dos electrones del litio
justo en el orbital interno
ese sería el primer nivel de energía y
luego tenemos que colocar uno más por lo
que el tercer electrón del litio está en
el segundo nivel de energía o el orbital
más alejado del núcleo en este ejemplo
aquí tenemos nuestros dos átomos que
puedes ver mientras vas hacia abajo en
un grupo mientras bajas tendrás un
incremento en el radio atómico
y eso es porque mientras vas hacia abajo
en un grupo está sumando electrones en
niveles de energía más elevados que
están más lejos del núcleo en este caso
sumamos este electrón a un nivel de
energía más alto está más alejado del
núcleo lo que significa que por supuesto
los átomos se harán cada vez más grandes
porque está sumándole más electrones
ahora veamos las tendencias por periodo
mientras temores a través de un periodo
en esta dirección
mientras base en esta dirección de hecho
verás que el radio atómico disminuye
veamos si podemos ver la razón pero
normalmente dibujando imágenes simples
de nuestros átomos el litio con número
atómico de 3 ya hemos hablado de eso hay
3 protones en el núcleo del litio
continuar escribiendo eso aquí 3
más es la carga positiva del núcleo en
el litio y tenemos que considerar los 3
electrones cierto nuevamente dos de esos
electrones estaban en el orbital
interior y luego tenemos a un electrón
en el orbital exterior
la idea es algo como ese
ahora pensemos en lo que le pasará a ese
electrón de afuera como resultado de su
posición este electrón afuera en magenta
será atraído más cerca del núcleo el
núcleo está cargado positivamente el
electrón está cargado negativamente y
entonces el núcleo cargado positivamente
va a atraer a ese electrón más cerca de
él al mismo tiempo los electrones
interiores con carga negativa lo van a
repeler déjame continuar resaltando eso
estos de aquí son los electrones del
orbital interior cargas iguales se
repelen y podrías pensar que este
electrón de aquí empuja a este electrón
en esta dirección y que este electrón
quiere empujar a este electrón en esa
dirección
el núcleo atrae la carga negativa y los
electrones del orbital interior repelen
el orbital exterior y lo llamamos
blindaje porque los electrones del
orbital interior están blindando a ese
electrón magenta de la atracción del
núcleo
esto es llamado blindaje de electrones o
apantallamiento de electrones estos son
conceptos muy importantes ahora
continuamos dibujando el átomo para el
berilio tiene un número atómico de 4 y
entonces aquí está nuestro núcleo para
el berilio con un número atómico de 4
eso significa que hay 4 protones en el
núcleo una carga de cuatro más en el
núcleo y tenemos cuatro electrones de
los cuales preocuparnos esta vez
continuaré dibujando
electrones en mi orbital interno en mi
primer nivel de energía y luego tenemos
2 electrones en nuestro orbital exterior
o el segundo nivel de energía y
nuevamente este es sólo una simple
aproximación de cómo podría verse el
veril cuando pensamos en lo que está
pasando nos estamos moviendo de una
carga tres más en el litio a una carga
de cuatro más en el berilio y entre más
positivas sea tu carga atraerá más a
esos electrones exteriores y cuando
piensas en la idea de apantallamiento de
electrones nuevamente tienes a esos
electrones aquí brindando a estos
electrones del orbital exterior de los
efectos de ese núcleo de carga positiva
ahora podrías pensar que los electrones
del orbital exterior podrían blindar
también cierto podrías pensar que este
electrón aquí en magenta podría blindar
al otro electrón imagen
pero el problema es que los dos están
casi a la misma distancia del núcleo los
electrones del orbital exterior no se
blindan realmente los unos a los otros
lo hacen más que nada a estos átomos
internos ya que tienes el mismo número
de electrones internos brindando como en
el ejemplo del litio déjame continuar
resaltando eso tienes dos electrones
internos brindando en el berilio y
tienes dos electrones blindando en el
litio ya que tienes la misma cantidad de
blindaje pero tienes una carga positiva
mayor esos electrones exteriores
sentirán más atracción por el núcleo y
serán atraídos con mayor fuerza de la
que hubieras imaginado por lo menos
mayor que en nuestro ejemplo anterior
estos electrones son atraídos incluso
con mayor fuerza y debido a eso el átomo
de berilio será menor que el átomo de
litio esa es la tendencia si vas a
través de un periodo incrementará el
número de protones y ese aumento en la
atracción moverá a los electrones más
cerca y por ende disminuye el tamaño del
átomo
veamos el radio iónico ahora y este
concepto puede ser un poco complicado
dependiendo del tipo de química en la
que estés involucrado esta será una
versión muy simple si tomo un átomo
neutro de litio tengo a litio
siento y he dibujado esto varias veces
lo dibujaré una vez más tenemos nuestro
núcleo del litio que tiene tres
electrones así que nuevamente
dibujaremos a nuestros tres electrones
rápidamente dos electrones en el orbital
interno y un electrón en el orbital
exterior de esta manera y digamos que
formarás un campeón cierto quitarás un
electrón de nuestro átomo neutro
continuaré dibujando esto tenemos tres
protones en el núcleo y tres electrones
cancelándose a los unos con los otros
para poder ser un átomo neutro y si
quisiéramos quitar a uno de esos
electrones mostraré al litio perdiendo
un electrón
si el litio pierde un electrón perderá
ese electrón externo el núcleo aún tiene
una carga de más 3
tres protones en él y aún tenemos
nuestros dos electrones internos
pero quitamos al electrón del orbital
más alejado quitamos a este electrón en
magenta
déjame continuar resaltando eso perdimos
un electrón este electrón de aquí por lo
que puedes mostrarlo de esta manera y
haciendo eso ahora tenemos tres cargas
positivas en nuestro núcleo y sólo dos
electrones debido a eso el litio obtiene
una carga de más 1m y más es un camión
formamos un camión que es más pequeño
que el átomo neutro por sí mismo eso es
en cierta manera sentido común cierto si
quitas este electrón externo ahora
tienes tres cargas positivas en el
núcleo y sólo dos electrones aquí estás
atrayendo a esos dos electrones perdiste
el electrón exterior el radio se hace
más pequeña y entonces el cationes más
pequeño que el átomo neutro vemos que
los átomos neutros se hacen más pequeños
al convertirse en campeones
y eso tiene sentido porque si le agregas
un electrón a un átomo neutro aumentará
su tamaño y ese es nuestro siguiente
concepto aquí si tomas algo como el
cloro un átomo neutro de cloro y le
añades un electrón al cloro eso nos
daría una carga negativa nos daría un
cloro con carga negativa o debería decir
un año cloruro en términos de tamaños
continuamos dibujando un átomo
representativo aquí si éste es nuestro
átomo neutro de cloro y le añadimos un
electrón
de hecho aumentará bastante su tamaño el
año no es más grande que el átomo neutro
y veamos si podemos pensar en la razón
aquí si vamos a dibujar la configuración
electrónica si escriben la configuración
electrónica de gas noble para el cloro
neutro y deberías de saber cómo se hace
eso solo dibujaría a tu gas noble en
cort
y luego 3
7 electrones en el orbital exterior para
el átomo neutro del cloro para el año
oruro empezaras de la misma manera
escribirás al neón en corchetes
2 y la estás añadiendo un electro así
que en lugar de 3 p 5 sería 3 c
ahora tendremos a 8 electrones en el
orbital exterior
y esto nos dará sólo 7 electrones en
nuestro orbital externo la explicación
para el aumento en tamaño del año en
cloruro en la mayoría de los libros de
texto y escucharás a gente decir que la
suma de
este electrón
significa que esos electrones se repele
eran más los unos a los otros tienes
ocho en lugar de siete y entonces como
se repelen los unos a los otros más se
hace un poco más grande y eso tiene
sentido pero algunas personas están en
desacuerdo con esa explicación y no he
visto una mejor alternativa ofrecida
sinceramente así que de cualquier manera
en la que quieras pensar en ello
generalmente el avión es más grande que
un átomo neutro pero en términos de la
explicación para eso podrías pensar en
la repulsión de electrones si quisieras
dejar fuera el hecho de que algunas
personas no están de acuerdo con eso
podrías pensar en que el átomo tiene más
componentes como una manera muy sencilla
de pensar en ello
pero en general para los exámenes piensa
en que el año es más grande